Harrison doula's son Jason use an
impressive clearly Force enhanced
listening skill to get an idea of
ahsoka's whereabouts as he hears
Snippets of her experience in the world
Between Worlds don't you hear it
the show's choice to give Jason there
and forced listening abilities is
particularly interesting as the skill is
closely associated with a similarly
named character from an extremely dead
corner of the Star Wars lore Jason solo
the son of Han Solo and Leia Organa in
many ways Jason solo is a scarier Star
Wars villain than Darth Vader Jason's
path ultimately takes an unfortunate
turn and unlike kylo he goes all in on
the dark side as the Sith Lord Darth
kadus Jason becomes something of a
tragic villain he's also notorious for
picking up some of the stranger four
skills out there including of course
their enforced listening nevertheless
fans would have noticed that Ahsoka
chose to give one of his most famous
force abilities to a kid with the same
name look at the fact that he has access
to a similar Force ability being ominous
hint that is destined to follow a
similar path